hello YouTube chest lovers my friends
this is grunge in here and welcome to
the third part of my chess reputa
against the e4 now in this section when
your opponent plays d4 and you reply
with the move Aoife you are going to
learn what you should do after your
opponent plays B cross e file well here
certainly black should capture that pawn
so Knight cross ePHI and you can see I
have highlighted by the arrows over here
why it has a four good genuine reply so
let's see each reply by turn so the
first move which I want to see is Knight
to f3 after Knight to f3 black should
certainly play Queen to f6 and by
playing this more black has created the
first threat of the game so if y does
not respond accurately then white pawn
will be crippled and that will be a
great especially in the endgame so in a
way white has to deal with that tat so
there are two ways to deal with this so
let's look at the first option which is
the birth of this one Bishop to e2 so
not only protecting the knight but
planning to castle on the King side well
against this there is a very good move
that more often you will play in this
line which is Bishop to b4 check
now after Bishop to b4 White has a three
replies but amongst those Bishop to d2
is the worst of all because it's just
one kind of trap in this line after
Bishop to d2 Black has a wonderful reply
which start with Knight cross f3 check
and after Bishop cross f3 we have queen
cross V 2 and not only black emerge with
a ball but with a very superior position
so that is one trap that white should
avoid so in a way White has a only two
reply either c3 or Knight B to d2 1 all
the way it will transpose to each other
so let's see the first reply which is
the c3 and here black should certainly
play Bishop to c5 you see the first
merit of Bishop to b4 check so in a way
it will take away the square for this
white knight to go to the c3 that means
this Knight has to passively go to the
either d2 or the e3 and let me reveal
the theory at this point so what black
is aiming in this kind of positions are
let's say your other night goes to the
e7 then you play d6 so free of the other
Bishop then the knight goes to the g6
and after simple castle on the King side
you can see I have highlighted by the
arrows what black one is either this
Bishop goes to the g4 or the d7
depending on the circumstances and this
night will slot into the f4 and
blackness slowly go for the King side
attack and that is the pretty much plan
of the black if white does nothing and
sit passively of course you will see in
your game many of your opponent will
disturb this plan but we will see from
my games how we are going to counter
those
so in my first game at this position my
opponent castle on the kingside and I
played as usual power theory Knight to
e7 and now my opponent plays night
crossed might so his idea is very simple
after Queen captures he plays Knight B
to d2 and after I castle on the Kings
side
please note white cannot play Knight to
f3 because the e4 pawn Hanks so my
opponent plays King to h1 and you have
to use to this kind of moves by the way
because if anyway white wants to retain
his advantage then he has to look out
for the move f4 it's a one kind of space
gaining move which why it is always play
sooner or later so in this game of
course my opponent was very high rated
so he knows this plan so he decided to
play for the f4 immediately and I
responded with Knight to g6 stopping the
f4 mu and now my opponent plays Queen to
c2 so probably his idea is to play
Knight to f3 because now that a pawn is
protected
I played D Phi so attacking one more
time to that pawn and stopping the
knight to f3 so he renewed this head
after Bishop to d3
I played Bishop to d6 so Bishop to d6 as
a direct threat to checkmate white on h2
and please note if my opponent played
Knight to f3 then the very simple reply
will be Queen to e5 followed by Bishop
to g4 and capturing that night and once
again creating threat so Knight to f3
it's not at all a good move after Bishop
to d6 so instead my opponent plays g3 so
dealing with that mid threat and here I
first of all played Bishop to h3 so
gaining time on the rook and after rope
to even I played
ruk ft8 so once again pressurizing that
pawn and the other idea of fruit to eat
is I want to provoke him to clay f4 and
which in fact he did so he played f4
here and I was waiting for this movement
because I can capture that pawn so after
G cross f4 and fin cross f4 again I have
created the main thread so my opponent
defended with very logically so Luke
goes to the e2 but afterwards I captured
the pawn and after Y to recapture I play
Bishop to g4 once again attacking the
rook and after only reply laughs for the
white Lucas Brooke - G - I played f5 so
once again attacking the bishop and in
the game my opponent give me this check
and after I put my King on h8 he
responded with Knight to f3 which looks
very logical because it creates a
discover attack to my queen but my
opponent completely overlooked my next
move which is queen cross f3 now cream
cause have three has a big merit first
of all it gained a piece it's spinning
this rook and not only that it's also
threatening to capture this bishop and
hear my opponent miscalculated this line
and he simply capture my queen which
allows me to give this tracks of rook
check and after the only Roop replied
rook to g1 I captured that Bishop once
again a chat and the only reply forced
is Queen to g2 afterwards I played a
very strong move which is rook to eat or
of course this was a blood scheme and
because of the time trouble he played
this horrific move which is queen cross
f3
afterwards I simply checkmate him that
is one game which illustrate how you can
handle when your opponent plays Bishop
e2 and c3
now in the second game my opponent
instead of c3 played Knight B to d2 and
my opponent was really high rated he was
around 2100 plus and I responded with as
per our usual theory Knight to e7 and he
plays c3 so I told you it's more or less
transposed to over main line so I played
Bishop to c5 and please remember there
is a one nasty trap exist here so if you
open I'm feeling very aggressive and if
you decided to play this move which is
b4 then Black has a fantastic reply
which is Bishop cross before please note
if C cross before then after Knight
takes comes with a check like an simply
snap up that crook so black will be an
exchange up so that's why C cross v4 is
not possible in the game I happen
responded with Queen to b3 but then
again comes the second dazzling
sacrifice which is bishop cross c3 and
please note again the Queen cannot
capture the bishop because of the night
cross f3 check in the game my opponent
plays rook to be one but after Knight
cross Knight and Bishop cross night I
remain a couple of points of straight
away no play so I won this game quite
easy so that is one trap if your
opponent plays b4 of course my opponent
was very high record so he castle over
here and after I plays d6 which free of
that Bishop he responded with the move
Knight to b3 attacking my bishop so I
dropped my bishop back to the b6 and
after he plays King to h1 which is a
very cunning move what's his idea is he
first of all wants to capture this night
and when Queen recaptures he wants to
play a phone so as I told you you have
to use to this scenario where white will
pin that F ball and goes for their phone
here I diffuse his plan with this
wonderful move which is nitrous f3 and
after Bishop cross f3
I simply castle on the kingside and now
my opponent plays Bishop to e2 so more
or less he just want to push the f4
that's fine but in this process he lost
one important tempo and that proves very
sufficient in the game here I responded
with Queen to e5 this is one of my own
recommendation whenever white is looking
for f4 you should always pressurize the
e4 pawn and you will see how effective
this can be so in the game my opponent
responded with Queen to c2 defending
that pawn and I renew the threat once
again by playing fi my opponent
desperately defended that pawn with
Bishop to d3 but after very simple F
cross E 4 and Bishop cross e4 I played
Bishop to a5 I just want to exchange the
pieces because I know my position is
very good for the endgame so here my
opponent captured this Bishop and after
Queen captures he once again captured my
Queen and after Knight cross F Phi my
opponent place slightly mistake and move
which is f3 so his idea is very simple
he wants to free up that rope because
that pawn was attacked by the bishop but
in this process he allowed my rook to
come to the 7 so I simply played rook to
e8 and after Bishop to g5 which is again
a big mistake it doesn't look like a
mistake at this point but you will see
in a minute why it's a big mistake so I
simply played
II - so attacking the b2 and my opponent
define it with rook to be one but after
very simple at six by black please note
the bishop cannot go to the edge for say
in the game my opponent responded with
Bishop to d2 but now comes the whole
idea which is Knight to h4 please note
this Bishop this vital Bishop is
covering all these critical diagonals
that means this route cannot support
this G pole and if the Jeep one is not
supported then how the hell on earth
white will see that pawn in the game my
opponent responded with g3 but after
very simple my cross f3 I have two
threats which is first place checkmate
the White King on h2 and the second is
to capture this piece and white cannot
avoid both defend so my opponent
resigned over here now after black plays
Queen to f6 the other option for the
white is to first of all capture this
Knight
so Knight cross e file and after queen
cross e-file you can see right now white
phone is attacked by the Queen so why it
has a too good reply so the first option
which I need to cover is Knight to c3
so trying to defend that pawn and here
the but obvious logical reply by the
black will be Bishop to b4 so pinning
that night and renewing the threat of
capturing that pawn
and here in one of my game my opponent
responded with Bishop to d2 and I
responded with Knight to f6 and then he
plays Bishop to d3 now please note here
if you want to play a very very
aggressive chess then you can go for the
d5 but to be honest with you personally
I don't like that line because your king
and the Queen is in line it's okay that
black can win a white pawn but then most
likely white will castle on the Kings
side and the rook will come on the
e-file and that can sometime proves very
disaster for the black so what I
recommend over here is instead of defer
should play here d6 a solid enough move
and in the game my upon responded with
castling on the King side and I played
Bishop to g4 attacking the Queen which
he defined it with f3 so f3 is not only
defending the Queen it's also protecting
the center and the good thing is right
now it's also attacking the bishop so
here first of all I played Bishop to c5
check and after King goes to the h1 I
played Bishop to d7 now as I mentioned
in my earlier games you have to use to
this move which is f4 so attacking the
Queen and gaining space in the center
here black should play Queen to e7 which
I did and my opponent responded with
Queen to f3 if you can see this is a
dream position for the white because not
only it's two rooks are collected but
white piece are actively placed and also
White has a center now first thing you
should look out is where these bishops
are looking at so if you look at this
bishops are strongly looking on the King
side
and also White has a center somewhat on
the kingside so considering all these
factors black has to decide which side
he wants to castle now if you castle on
the Kings side then all this tax comes
into the picture so by evaluating this
position I decided to castle on the
Queen side and my opponent responded
with Bishop to e3 neutralizing this
bishop so I captured that Bishop and
after Queen captures which has a merit
of attacking my a pawn so I just
defended with King to v8 and now my
opponent plays a4 so going for the pawns
from on the Queen side now here I
responded very energetically so it's
very important if your opponent is
playing on the flank
you should always play in the center and
that's what I did so I played defy so
please note that Paul is right now pin
opponent decided to grab more space and
he plays ePHI and I responded with
Knight to g4 attacking the Queen and the
Queen drawbacks to the f3 now I played
defy attacking the knight please note
Knight to defy can be successfully made
by Queen to h4 so in the game my
opponent decided to play Knight to e4
then I played fi and again if he would
to capture this fall with on poisson
then i will recapture with the jeep on
and in that case my G file will be open
up and that will decree it for attacking
chances so my opponent plays Knight to
g5 and after s6 the knight drawbacks to
the h3 and if you look at the last few
moves of the white all the white was
doing is the night dance so this night
was come from c3 to e4 to g5 and now it
goes to the h3
but meanwhile during this whole process
white has weakened up this juicy III
square which I explored magnificently so
I played first of all night to e3
attacking the rook and after rook - even
I played Bishop to say six and now you
see the dark side of that Knight moves
so not only this Bishop is attacking the
Queen but this night and Bishop are
attacking the loose g2 square which
white is hard-pressed to defend in the
game my opponent plays Queen to e2 but
after very simple Bishop cross due to
when King to g1 I simply snap up that
night and if you look at this position
black has a wonderful extra night posted
on e3 which as supported by extra pawn
on d4 so that is one game which will
give you an idea how you can play when
your opponent play Knight to c3
the second good reply for the white at
this position is Bishop to d3 so
defending that pawn and here black
should certainly play Bishop to b4 check
and again
White has few choices now if you operand
plays Bishop to d2 then very simple will
be queen cross B 2 and again black will
emerge with a pawn up so that we have
seen already in the last games so in
this game my opponent responded with c3
and I simply drop my bishop back to the
c5 and now my opponent castle on the
kingside here
I played Knight to f6 attacking the e4
and my opponent responded with King to
h1 so as I mentioned and I'm mentioning
again and again white moves order are
leading to the play
f4 so here I place d6 no need to worry
and indeed f4 is coming and whenever f4
is coming in this 9
the queen is better placed on e7 so
remember this move you should play the
Queen to e7 and after night 2 d2 here I
place castling on the King side it is
very dangerous to go on the queenside
castle because you can see White has
already committed c3 and sometimes when
you castle on the Queen side then the b4
+ a4 come in a flash so that's why it's
not wise to castle on the Queen side
when your opponent plays C 3 so that's
why I decided to castle on the King side
now here I have two games for you in the
first game my opponent plays Queen to f3
where I played Bishop to d7 and after B
for attacking the bishop my bishop
simply drops pax to v6 and after a 4 I
simply stop that pawn to go further with
the move fr and now my opponent blocked
the Queen side with the moon d5 but can
you believe this
that game is about to over it looks
unbelievable but you will see in a
minute what kind of disasters are
looming to the white so what I did here
is played Knight to g4 so you can see my
idea is very simple my knight wants to
jump to the e3 Square
it has been centralized very well and to
defuse this threat my opponent plays
Knight to c4 which looks very logical
because not only its dropping Knight to
e3 but this Knight is also capturing
this good Bishop so what's wrong about
it
can you guess blacks next move I give
you a few seconds can you identify
amazing move by black
and that move is night cross hash to Pam
and first side it looks impossible
because current white can catch that
night now please note this night is
right now attacking Queen in a row so
the white reply is pretty much force
white cannot capture this night if I'd
capture this night then that leads to
the losing the Queen because you can see
that King does not have any space to
hide so white has to forcefully play
Queen to h3 afterwards black will simply
snap of that Queen so that's why King
cross s2 it's impossible so in the game
my opponent decided to play Queen to h5
and give up the exchange so I simply
capture the rook and now he plays this
efile cheap threat to chat with me on at
7:00 but again this was a blitz game and
my opponent completely overlooked this
move which is Knight to g6 [ __ ] a
king and a queen and that's the end of
the game
in the second game at this position
instead of last Queen f3 in this game my
opponent decided to gambit upon for the
initiative so here my opponent plays
ePHI attacking the knight and after
captures captures and Queen captures
White's
idea is to play Knight to f3 gaining
time on the Queen and more pcs are
coming towards my king so here black
doesn't need to afraid and in the game I
found out a wonderful move by the Queen
which is Queen to h5 so if the knight
moves then I can simply exchange the
Queen so my opponent plays over here
Bishop to f4 and I further increase the
pressure on the knight with Bishop to g4
my opponent drop his bishop back to e 2
and now I simply play rook a to d8
attacking the Queen after Queen goes to
the a4 i centralized my other look which
is rook f2 even again attacking the
piece of white and in the game my
opponent defended the bishop with rook a
to even but he completely overlooked my
this mu which is rook to e-file so it's
attacking Queen and the bishop and white
cannot defend both the pieces
now the third option here is night 2 d2
which was the case against one of my
opponent which is very high rated around
2200 Plus on chest capable so here I
responded with Knight to f6 and hear my
opponent castle on the Kings side and I
plates d6 and now he plays f4 so
attacking my queen as I told you in my
previous video wherever white place f4
you should place your queen on e7 so
that's what I did and now my opponent
plays c3
now instead of c3 in one game one of my
opponent plays Knight to f3 and I simply
played Knight cross E 4 and after Bishop
cross and queen cross please remember
this Bishop is covering the vital even
square so my opponent plays c3 and his
idea was now he wants to play the rook -
even but when you place f4 this is the
thing that goes into the favour for the
black so I simply give this check Bishop
c5 and after king - h1 i simply cast on
the King side and here why it has
nothing but upon down situation so if
your opponent plays Knight to f3 this is
how you can handle that's why at this
position my opponent plays c3 and after
Bishop to c5 check and King goes to the
edge fun as I mentioned in other video
that it's very hard for black to castle
on the Queen side because p44 are coming
very very quickly so that's why I
decided to castle on the King side and
now my opponent plays Queen - even so
planning is very simple this Queen wants
to go either to g3 or to the h4
depending on the circumstances so I
played rook to e8 so pressurising move
to the Ipoh
and now my opponent responded with b4
when after Bishop to d6 my opponent
plays Bishop to b2 so finally he is
developing his all pieces and here I
responded with fi attacking the ball and
he just protect that pawn one more time
with the move a3 now I plays Bishop to
d7 so here
black is also completing his all piece
development now let's see how we are
going to progress from here onwards so
in the game my opponent decided to play
c4 which has a mallet of attacking the
knight and unleashing the bishop and I
responded with a cross before and after
a cross B for exchange of one pair of
rooks so rou cross rook and Bishop cross
rook here I place Knight to g4 idea is
very simple I wants to put the knight or
the bishop on e3 so my opponent
responded with roof to f3 stopping
penetration on e3 and here I place
fi please note White's epon is pinned
right now
so my opponent responded here with the
move s3 attacking my knight but then
after some calculation I goes for this
sequence so I place F cross E for
attacking to piece
so my opponent's response is pretty much
force my opponent plays Knight cross e
for and here I place bishop to c6 so now
you can see three pieces are tracking
the night
and my opponent captured my night and I
recaptured night with the bishop and
after Bishop takes Queen takes my
opponent responded with Queen to c3
which has a direct threat to made me on
g7 here I responded with first of all
this Queen check and after King to s2
Bishop to Jeevan chair and after King to
h3 I simply snap up the Queen and after
my opponent recapture with the rule I
simplify more with Bishop to d4 and
after Roop to c1 Bishop takes Bishop and
rook takes Bishop I deliberately goal
for the ending because I knew that this
ending favors the black and the reason
is because of the blacks next move rook
to e4 so you can see right now this rook
is attacking f4 and c4 and white cannot
defend both the ball so in the game my
upon responded with rook to e7 attacking
my b7 pole but after rue cross F for
route cross b7 and Rakosi for black is
clearly upon up and in the game I
managed to push my D pawn up to the ball
and when the real so that is how you can
play against Knight to d2 system